[Applause]
I'm retiring well in that case what are
we drinking same for the goddaughter God
told me you found something
on a train during the war a dial that
could change the course of history why
are you chasing the thing that drove
your father crazy
he'll move please get out of here
stop
sorry
Dr Jones get him
[Music]
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
this way
[Applause]
tighten your seat belt there might be
some tablets you've taken your chances
made your mistakes
now a final Triumph
India give him hell Indiana Jones a few
times in my life I've seen things
I'm gonna torture with voodoo
been shot nine times
including once by your father
ah I'm sorry
and I've been looking for this
all my life
[Music]